oggi cuciniamo un bel piattone di pasta
eh la pentola iniziamo ovviamente a
mettere eh l'acqua all'interno mettiamo
anche il timer che è importante mettiamo
la pasta si deve mettere Ovviamente
anche il sale Questa cosa è molto
importante ragazzi attenzione a non far
scendere la pasta ma solo l'acqua
perfetto yes come on tagliamo appunto Il
Chili Pepper i piccoli pezzi condimento
Io ci metterei sopra un bel pesce fresco
mettiamo il pesce all'interno della
nostra pasta e andiamo a prendere un
filino d'olio con goccino perfetto ed è
pronto per essere servito Ma prima una
bella foto per Instagram e voilà
Seguitemi per altre ricette